- So today, yeah, I've been busy.
I've been real busy lately,
but I've been doing everything
for the better interest of people.
Mostly sometimes, yeah,
and I just sit there, and I
look at how life is right now,
and it's crazier than shit.
- [Mark] Right now, especially?
- And I look like shit?
- [Mark] You look great.
You're talking about because of COVID
or because of other things?
- [Ruby] I've got COVID.
- [Mark] You have it?
- [Ruby] Nope, they told me I don't.
So I don't know.
I don't know what COVID is anymore.
- [Mark] (laughs) None of us do.
( Rudy laughs)
But I did...
Oh, guess what I found today?
- [Mark] What'd you find?
- Are you recording me right now?
- [Mark] I am, yeah.
- Okay, I found this thing.
It was a blue crap, and
it had little stickers
like that Asian snake.
Ooh, it's testicles thingies.
Ooh, God, the little pinchers,
like the snake.
I said, "God damn, I've
seen everything in life,
but this is some sick shit."
That's why I don't get
in the ocean over my hip.
You won't find me in there.
Only if I'm on a boat-
- [Mark] When was the last time
you've been in the ocean?
- It's been a minute.
And I think there it went.
There's one of them.
That one just, a flew donkey right now.
- [Mark] You spend your time
during the day going where?
Cause you drift around, right?
- Yeah, so I stay with a friend,
and it's all right there.
- [Mark] You do?
- Yeah, but he has...
Everybody has that shit with the rat.
I'm gonna take it out today.
It's caught.
- [Mark] What's that?
- The rats. We're gonna
get rid of them today.
- [Mark] You have rats?
- Because that's what it is.
- [Mark] There are rats where you stay?
- I don't know what we have to
do, but I can't close it up.
I had to take them out. You hear me?
- [Mark] I hear ya.
- So we got to take it
out because that does...
How do you know if it goes
in the bottom of your foot
that if somebody cut your foot?
So one time, five years
ago, seven years ago,
I got bit in the county jail by a spider
on the side of my head right here,
and it boiled up
into a whole bunch of
little bubbles, right?
Like a little bubble.
Like that morning I woke up, and I said,
"Ow, it hurts real bad."
Well, it was a spider that bit me.
I didn't know what kind of spider.
Then I was thinking,
well, when I was a little
girl at five years old,
my grandma said,
"In the ceiling, I hear
this ti-ti-ti-ti sound,"
and it was like a beetle,
or some kind of a spider, right?
In the attic. Not the
attic, but in the ceiling.
Now, I don't know how...
what the fuck it was, but
it was something different.
It wasn't of this...
Yeah. It was a (indistinct)
And I would only hear it very often.
- [Mark] Ruby?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Where'd you grow up?
- Garden Grove.
- [Mark] Garden Grove. That's
right, we talked about this.
- I love Garden Grove. I
love all the people there.
- [Mark] Your childhood was good?
- Everything was good.
Everything was excellent.
But then I met...
I don't know, just jealousy, I guess.
It has to be that
because I'm not gonna give up anything
that I got for anybody.
Like I know what I'm going
through is for a reason
because God came and seen me.
Jesus came to see me.
And I've seen him two times.
And he told, "You're a fuckin bitch."
He told me first. (laughs)
That's the word Jesus said.
You fucking motherfucker.
I said, "Why'd you say it?"
And, "Fuck you, God," I said it like that
cause I tell him like that sometimes,
"Fuck you, God," I'll tell him like that.
Well, then I was talking to him,
and then I said, "Well,
what would you like, sir?"
And he said, "A drink of water."
And I said, "What'd you say, sir?"
And he said, "A drink water."
And I said, "Okay, I'll be right back."
So I didn't know what to tell him.
I said, "Did you have
anything else to tell me?
Am I am okay? Am I gonna
make it to Heaven?"
I said. (laughs) He didn't answer me.
I said, "All right, Lord,
it's nice to meet you."
I said, "I can't believe
I just met the Lord."
I said, "But you are my Father in Heaven,
And you are my Father on Earth as well."
And I said, "I don't know
what else to tell you, Lord.
I don't know," I said.
But I was bored. At the time, I was bored.
Like most people would
want to sit there and...
No, I was like, "Dude, I'm outta here."
So I knew I wasn't going
back with water, right?
So he comes another day, and
he's walking down the street,
and I said, "Lord," this
was like a couple...
maybe like four days later,
I said, "Lord, what are you
doing walking the street again?
I said, "What the hell is wrong with you?
Why don't you go back up
to Heaven where it's fine?"
Why don't you...
I said, I don't wanna go.
Oh, I asked him like this
too, with the first time,
I said, "Dear Lord, it's up to you."
"Nice to meet you," I
said, but it's up to you
if I can stay on earth, or if
I'm going to Heaven with you,
I don't know."
And he said...
I said, "Would you please grant me to stay
on this Earth right now?"
I said, "I'm not ready to go yet home."
And he didn't say nothing to me.
I said, "Okay then."
So I said...
So he granted me my wish.
Then, so the next time I met him,
so he was walking this way
and he said, "You're a bitch,"
or some shit.
He said, "You're a fuckin bitch,"
and he kept on walking,
and I was like, "Lord,
what's what's the matter?
Are you mad at me?"
And then, so he kept on walking,
and he turned back around
and started walking this way.
And so I said, "Hey,
something ain't right here."
I said, "You need to send
angels to my Lord right now.
Bring your best angels you got in Heaven."
And I said, "Bring them down here
and watch over my Lord.
Something ain't right
because he's a human
being, you understand?"
He really is. He just
woke up from the dead.
And he can walk on water.
And he's amazing to me,
and he gives me everything I
need and I could ever want,
but I don't know and right now...
I told him like this,
I said, "Lord, send the best
angels from Heaven right now
for my Lord because somethings not right."
And the next thing I know,
I looked down there, and he's walking,
and there's a football.
There's a guy, he's a robot football,
and he's going like this. (laughs)
Like back and forth, right?
(laughs) Just like wiggling.
And I said, "Oh, shit!" (laughs)
That's what I'm talking about, you know?
And yeah, so I know the Lord.
And I know there's demons on this Earth.
I know. I've seen them.
And I'm not high, and I'm not dosed
because in the drains I look,
and like it's a sucker
fish holding this shit in.
If it's anything,
it's that sucker fish
they got from the ocean,
and it's sucking, and it's
not letting shit come out,
but it'll open, if it smells, let it out.
And they come out.
But then I seen this trash bag one night.
It's like a trash bag and millions...
I swear to God, don't
think I'm crazy, okay?
(siren wailing)
Billions of rats was
coming out of this bag.
It's like a sack or something, right?
And I said, "That's not fuckin possible."
And we're looking,
and I'm on the street. and
it's really going down,
and it was the craziest
thing I ever seen in my life.
It's the most weirdest thing
I ever seen in my life.
And I don't understand.
Yeah. Just, I don't know.
I don't get this.
How we get rats.
What's doing it?
It's dispose.
And if I can't shut them down,
then I have no...
I don't know how much
longer I can live with this.
Everybody else is
living, so I'm gonna live
cause I've got good people on my team.
No matter what, they give me my medicine.
Even if it's a robot sitting in, anything,
they give me a shot or
whatever I need at that moment.
Or it's the Lord.
And then when I seen the devil,
I was with Biggie Smalls,
We were talking, and I just came...
A week or before, I couldn't find him.
I said, "Where were you?"
He said, "On an Island."
And I said, "Oh, yeah."
And he said, "Yes."
I said, "Ah, then you're on vacation?"
He said, "Yeah, whatever, yeah."
I said, "Yeah, well, your
back here now, so whatever.
Do you wanna stay here in your apartment?
What do you want?"
I said, "Why don't you camp out here
in this fucking shit hole
of a (indistinct) desert?
Why are we here?"
So, why of all places, LA here?
Why can't we be in downtown LA
where it's really fuckin
rough and shit, you know?
- [Mark] Ruby, what do you dream about?
Do you sleep, even?
- [Ruby] I don't dream.
- [Mark] You don't dream.
- [Ruby] I don't.
- [Mark] Do you sleep?
- [Ruby] I just sleep.
And when I sleep and
somebody could kill me,
and I don't know it.
- [Mark] I'll bet.
- [Ruby] My friend, he stabs
me in the head with his knife,
and I'll go out for a minute,
and he'll wake me up when
he's pulling it out. (laughs)
He's crazier than shit.
He's my friend though, and
he's a nut. He's a nutty boy.
My friend Brian told me,
"If you ever kill anyone,"
He would tell, "Yeah." (laughs)
I said, "Just me? Why me?
Why do you always pick me to do that?"
He said, "Because I
wanted try it one time,
see if I could wake you up."
I said, "Well, I think you did it."
So he did it again.
He said, "I just had to check
for myself one more time."
I said, "That's it motherfucker. (laughs)
No more times, okay?"
And he said, "Okay."
But yeah, and it's weird.
Like life is weird how all
these people are coming back,
and I haven't woke one up for a while
because I don't want to, right?
I don't know.
But like I know I woke the Lord back up.
He was dead.
I know someone killed him.
I know that for a fact.
And I woke him back up.
So, and there's girls
and women that have died,
and they come by me, and
I'm just like, "Wow."
And my friends, the first thing they do is
they come and see me.
As soon as they wake up,
everybody comes and sees me.
It's the weirdest thing
I've ever seen in my life.
Why I have that gift? I'll never know.
Why God has picked me to be this?
I don't know anymore.
I'm like, I hate everything right now.
Just because they targeted me.
And I never did nothing to nobody. (sobs)
Well, I wanna see my
people, and I'm going to.
No matter where they're
at, I'm gonna find them.
I don't care.
Whenever I unlock that one door
down in that cellar, wherever it was,
1,800 feet or 1,600 feet
and underneath ground,
and there's one elevator up and one down.
You wouldn't be scared.
That was must take like 10 minutes
to get down to where you're going
or even a little longer,
maybe 15 or 20 minutes.
And to know that you're never
coming out of that spot again?
I couldn't do it to anybody.
So I've learned a lot.
Like Cortell has always taught me
because they have the best.
They are the terminator.
I'm not lying to you.
They have cloned people.
Thank God. Jesus showed me this big thing.
It's like a salad. (laughs)
And I said, "Well, how
are you fuckin stacking
those motherfuckers?"
I asked him like that.
"How do you stack them?"
(siren wails)
I said, "Wow, so you cloned
every person that you wanted?"
And he said, "Yeah."
So I said, "You taught my dad
how to do that shit, huh?"
Cause my friends, one of them right here,
1677, he was born.
Another one, Vicente Fernandez,
he told me he was born in 1739.
I have a hermaphrodite friend.
She was back in the...
I don't know, where
they'd have big parades.
There was big ass elephants, huge ones,
and they're like little
people like the gypsy days,
shit like that.
And I'm just like,
"Is this shit really real, or
are they just fuckin with me?
Like, is this all really real?
I don't know, you know?
Because I mean...
I don't know.
But today is the day.
I said today is the day it's
coming out, no matter what,
cause I found that blue thing.
Now if there's nothing else in my body,
I got it.
For sure, I got it.
- [Mark] So I ask this
question of a lot of people
that I interviewed,
what's the most important
lesson you've learned?
- The most important lesson, always study.
You never stop learning.
That's the most important thing.
When I heard that, when I was like...
I think I was five years
old when I heard that.
My teacher said never stop learning.
If there's anything, we'd go in class,
she'd say, "Good morning.
You never stop learning.
Today, we're gonna learn."
And that's all right.
So like, yeah, I always am doing...
And that's why maybe I
have the worst case maybe,
but right now at this time,
I had to get it all out,
and then I gotta...
As soon as I get it out of me,
and I tell guys, sew up.
Go get some...
You get...
What is that called?
Super glue.
And you glue up your inside,
that's what you do, you glue it.
With super glue. I swear to God.
That's the only thing
because it has to be fast
because when I got the
stitches in my head,
when somebody hit me over the
head with a brick real hard,
it cracked my whole skull open.
My skull's still cracked.
- [Mark] When did this happen?
- It happen in the valley a long time ago.
But, yeah, I don't know. (laughs)
I don't know. I can't explain it.
- [Mark] Ruby, you're so fascinating.
- God and I wanted out so bad.
It's like, "Why don't you just like fester
out of there or something?"
It's this one. When I go
outside, I gotta do it.
Watch, I'm gonna do it.
- [Mark] All right, Ruby.
Thanks for coming by again.
- Yeah, sure, man. I'm not crazy.
I haven't lost my mind.
I'm not going to a mental ward.
And I do this for him
because I like my friend.
I hate saying he's my friend
because it's really scary, life out there.
And I hate that word right now, friend,
because it's so scary for you guys.
And they locked him downstairs,
I said, all right, that's
one of us, I'll be checking.
That's why I don't leave here right now.
So why people they're
watching you at all times,
And you'll be sick. I promise you that.
I believe that.
- It's great feedback.
That's great to know.
- Yes, sir.
Or I'm doing everything
I can to protect him.
Cause I have my ways.
So I know if you're in here,
a lot of people can't do it no more.
Even if it's upstairs, downstairs,
I don't give a fuck what
they try side to side,
they can't keep you in here.
Now, that's what's weird.
The equators right across the street.
Do you know that?
- [Mark] The equator?
- The equator.
(Mark laughs)
- Listen to me, that door
across the street is hollow.
The equator is right in underneath us.
I don't know how they leveled the deck,
but it's a hole all the way
down, and it goes around.
I don't know how far in the
seat, but it's right here.
I swear by God on my life.
I asked the wetbacks, right?
I said, "Is it right here?"
And he said, "Yep, cause
I found it one day."
And he said, "Yes, it is."
And I said, "I found it, finally."
So the real...
Not the equator, but
the like abominable pit,
go down, down, down, it's
right across the street.
So if you'd need to dispose of any bodies,
I'd tell them to drop
it right there. (laughs)
You get rid of everything.
- [Mark] All right, thank you, Ruby.
- [Ruby] Yes, sir.
That's the truth, brother. You hear me?
- [Mark] You're always fascinating.
- [Ruby] I wouldn't lie to you.
That's what they told
me and they're right.
- [Mark] Yeah, I'll bet they are.
- [Ruby] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Will you hit me with that thing?
Do you got a better one today?